- [Mark] Ronnie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Ronnie] I'm from Texas,
Galveston, Texas.
[Mark] Galveston, Texas.
[Ronnie] Yes, sir.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
did you have both your parents growing up?
- No, just my mom and if
fact nine kids in the family
and just my mom, you know,
and she was an alcoholic.
So, you know, she didn't
pay attention too much,
you know, to what was going
on with her, in the house.
- [Mark] Where was dad?
- He was away, I don't know exactly where
but he was in some other town.
- [Mark] Did you ever meet your dad?
- I met him, but it was like,
I never like got to spend
time with him, you know.
- [Mark] And how was,
how would you describe your childhood?
- It was horrible, man.
You know my big brother, I was seven,
my big brother used to
like rape me, at night.
And then my brother, next, under him,
he used to pee in the bed, right?
And put me in the pee and I
used to get whippings for that.
Like I peed, you know what I mean?
He used to push me over into the pee
and he'd get into the dry
part, you know, where I was.
And also I had like a
babysitter, you know, Fuchsia,
that make me do things,
sexual things, you know.
It was, you know, it just
wasn't right, you know?
- So you're getting it from your brother
as well as the babysitter.
- Yeah.
- How long did this go on?
- From like five years, you know,
from seven to 12.
You know.
- Wow. So how were your teenage years?
How were you in high school?
- I couldn't focus too well, you know,
on the school, that grade, you know,
because I was like, my mind
just wandered, you know,
about what had happened to me.
And I just couldn't focus
on too much there, you know.
So I was in like a special
ed class, you know.
Like one hour a day I had a class
for the special ed kids like me,
slow kids, for one hour a day, you know.
It just wasn't, it wasn't like
it should've been to me, you know.
It was ugly.
- And then after high school,
where'd you go from there?
- Well, after high school, I just,
well, see what happened
when I was 15, right.
I was 15.
My sister became my guardian,
because my mom was never
there, my oldest sister.
So she sent me to San Diego, California,
when I was 15 years old.
Because I had a brother
right, that stayed there
and he had a one bedroom
apartment, two kids and a wife.
So when I got there, you
know, that was, you know
it wasn't like, it wasn't comfortable man.
So I took to the streets, you know
I just took to the streets
and kind of like survived.
And then I had to go to school.
So he put me in school.
I went to the Lincoln High School.
- So you were living on the
streets during high school?
- No.
Like I would live like with
different people, you know?
Know, different friends I
met, I would live with them.
And you know, went to school.
- During high school?
- Yeah.
- So you weren't really
at home with your family?
- No.
- My family, remember I
got sent to San Diego.
- Oh, I see.
- When I was 15.
- Okay.
- And from San Diego, I came here in 2004.
I was pitching to go, my
sister sent me to San Diego,
you know, at 15, you know,
it was like, what am I to do?
You know what I mean?
So I got sent to San Diego,
my brother, after I left his place
he had a one bedroom, like
I said, two kids and a wife.
Well, you know, where was I sleeping?
You know what I mean?
So I left and just went to the
streets, downtown San Diego,
in sassy bars I'd met people
and then he came and found me
and he said you gotta go to school.
We gotta put you in school.
So I said okay, you know,
so I went to school,
I met, you know, because I
was in like a little hotel,
you know.
I started meeting friends
and that's why, staying
with them, you know.
Because you know, they
went to school with me,
so I started staying with them.
You know, their mom was out
like, where do you know,
because I was quiet, I didn't
bother people, you know.
I wasn't trouble for nobody, you know.
Because I just been going through
so much in my head that happened to me
that I can't focus on
too much and not enough.
So I don't, you know, I
wasn't a problem for people.
- So your adult life has been
spent doing what, mostly?
- Mostly man, just
running the streets, man.
Getting from place to place, you know.
That's about it.
- So now today you're living on skid row.
- Yep.
- You're in a tent.
- Well, no, I sleep by the bank,
by bank of America.
And I have a friend that left a sheet,
I keep some of my little,
whatever I have in this tent.
And then in the morning
I come, get what I need,
bring my blanket, put it
back, you know, like that.
- So you just have a blanket?
- Because I have...
- So you just have a
blanket on the street?
- Yeah. I have a blanket
and I sleep in the back of
the Bank of America, you know.
Because I don't trust people man.
He just want me to, you can sleep in here,
sleep in the chair, whatever you know,
make you a bit, I don't trust people.
I can't. You know what I mean?
- Do you think the cause
of that is what happened
to you when you were young?
- I know it gotta be man.
Because I just, people be offering me,
you know, to sleep over at
their places or whatever
I pass. You know, I'm all right, you know?
And then one time the guy said to me
I could come take a
shower on 7th and Main.
Used to be a poster
house and then official.
And I went in there and I said,
come on we want to come
take a shower, you know,
to freshen up. And I
said all right, thanks.
And I didn't even know him.
And he tried to rape me, man.
He would have like one
prosthetic leg, he was,
I guess he was from the
military or whatever.
Yeah. But he, the security
guard had to cover,
I'm in there struggling with him inside.
You know what I mean?
I'm, like, see that's why,
that's I don't trust people.
They'd be nice to you.
I guess it gets in a situation where,
I mean, they figure they
can take control, you know.
- Have you ever been
married or do you have kids?
Nope.
- Never had a desire for it.
- Are you straight or gay?
- I'm straight, you know, sometime, I mean
I'm not gonna lie, from
what happened to me,
you know, sometimes I mingle with a man,
but I prefer women you know.
If my preference is a woman, you know.
- And what do you do for money now?
- I just ask people,
I stand at the stoplights
and you know, ask people for...
- You panhandle?
- Yeah. He's on the freeway, you know.
- Are you using drugs at all?
- I smoke weed and I drink a little beer
I don't like hard liquor.
Yeah.
But you know, my life is
so like messed up, man.
But like drugs, I've tried it.
I can't deal with it.
If people try to take
advantage of you to own that,
when you have to use that.
You know, they used that as a device
to get what they want from you.
I'd rather just smoke my little weed
every now and then and
take a beer, you know.
You know, I tried that, it don't work.
That people would take advantage of you.
- And then, I'm sure you credit that
what happened to you when
you were a young boy?
- Yeah. I think when I was a kid,
it just screwed my life up.
You know.
It screwed my life up.
- Do you ever talk with your
brother ever since then?
- Man, he act like it never happened, man.
That was years ago I
seen him in San Diego.
He act like it never happened.
I never talk about it,
you know what I mean?
Once I said, man, why
you should do that to me?
He go, what are you
talking about? Shut up.
You don't even know what's going on.
I would never, man.
He say, you'd better shut up
and you better not never say
nothing about that, you know.
He like, you know like, you know like
I clearly did never
say something, you know
And I was terrified that he
would, you know what I mean?
So I credit that to,
all that to what happened to me, you know.
It's just that, you just
don't do that to people.
A kid? Come on man.
No. I would never do that to nobody.
It's horrible.
- Yeah. It must be.
So where do you see your
life going from here?
How old are you now?
- I'm 59.
- 59.
- Yeah.
Plus I got hit by two
cars man. 2018 and 2013.
That's why my, that's why
I'm crippled, you know.
I'll probably never walk, be
normal again, walk normal.
But I want to try to do something man.
I don't know what it is, whatever,
whatever God put me to do, sets up for me.
I'm on the side of that.
I'll like to like work with
kids and stuff, you know.
Probably getting a job like
just chatting to kids about
living, be a what you call it?
like a motivational speaker
or something, you know,
to be able to go to youth centers
and talk to kids, you know,
and let them know, how,
you know, to speak out if
something happens to you
that you lot are not comfortable with.
Speak out. Tell somebody about it.
Don't just let it happen to you.
Because I didn't do that,
I let it happen to me.
- Do you ever get a chance
to talk about it with anyone?
- Nah. Like you?
You know, he told me
you was a good person,
he said man, feel comfortable
to tell your real story
to him, because he's, he
says he's a good person.
And I know, I know, you know,
he's a good, the guy treated me good.
You know, if he got food
he would give it to me,
you know, whatever.
- Yeah.
You know. He would make sure
people don't mess with me
and stuff, you know?
So I trust him, I trust him.
- Yeah.
- And he told me about you, so.
I, I feel comfortable with
you, opening up to you.
- Well, your story, I
think there must be others
out there...
- Man. I know, man.
I'm not so proud that
I'm not going to share
that I went through stuff like that.
- Somebody else experienced
something similar.
- Yeah. But they don't, they
probably scared to tell,
to speak out about it, you know?
- It's probably very
helpful to hear your story.
- Yeah. I hope so.
I hope we could help
somebody else and stop
if something happened to them like that,
we could help them to stop it, you know.
Maybe they'd tell somebody
and something could be done
about it. You know what I mean?
- Or a parent might be a little more aware
of what's going on.
- Yeah. A parent might
say, let me start to check,
I need to check, my God,
no wonder my child's acting like this.
They need to start checking into them
and making sure the child's good,
make sure they're okay.
If anything or body bothering them
taking advantage of them
sexually or whatever.
But I hope we could help
somebody else, you know,
I really...
- It sure will.
- I really pray that it will, you know.
It's the first time I ever
did something like this,
but, hey, maybe I should have been here,
to help somebody else that way.
- Yeah.
Do you feel like you're an angry person?
You don't seem angry.
- I'm not, you know, because
I realized that I was a kid.
I was taken advantage of,
you know, I trusted the people
I shouldn't have trusted.
You know, I just, you
know, I can't be angry.
It's something I have to live with.
It happened.
Okay. It happened.
So, I have to live with it.
So why should I be angry?
Take it out on some other kid
or do something like that.
You know what I mean?
That's not going to make things different
for what happened to me.
So, you know, I love, I love people.
I just don't trust everybody.
I don't trust going to
people's apartments.
You know what I mean, stuff like that,
I used to spend all night,
I just don't trust you.
You know. I'd rather be outside.
Well, you know, maybe they
can't do that to me outside,
somebody will see him, you know.
I even had my friend, that they,
the guy that was killing
the homeless people,
killed my friend. The guy they
caught that was going around
killing homeless people
taking their backpacks.
My friend got killed by him, you know.
I've seen my friend two
days before it happened.
You know?
So I'm like, man, I'm
glad they caught that guy.
You know?
I realized that there's some
bad people in this world.
There's some good people.
Now I don't admit to know you,
but I, my spirit, I'm
comfortable around you.
I'm comfortable, you know?
And I'm glad I'm doing this because like,
I hope we could help somebody.
- Yeah. If that helps
you to talk about it too.
- And it helps me to free,
it takes a load off me,
it takes a big old load off of me.
You know?
To be able to sit here
and talk about this.
- Excellent. Well,
Ronnie, thank you so much
for coming in.
- Anytime, man.
- And sharing your story.
- I'm glad, I'm grateful for you.
- Thank you man.
- Thank you. Peace.